on this episode I talk about the edge or
the center selling cats and jabs and
right hooks
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
you're watching the askgaryvee show
welcome to episode 8 of the askgaryvee
show eight the little fun fact for that
number is that is broadway browning
nagels number look it up
Eric asks do you believe in Jim Collins
belief that you can only focus on three
things Eric as a very under red
undereducated gentleman I don't know all
the details of mr. Collins's three
things that we can focus or the thesis
behind it but I will tell you that I'm a
contradiction on this question I
oftentimes I think that if you're doing
more than one thing you're not doing
anything and so when I focus on building
businesses I try to focus on one core
thing but look at me right now I've
never been busier in my life and I've
decided to start another video show
here's my theory focus on one thing and
make that 80 to 90 percent of your nut
and then have 20 percent 10 to 20
percent of complete and utter chaos
trying things probably losing because
you're not focused on them but it keeps
life spicy and interesting that's what
works for me the truth is I have a
feeling this works very differently for
everyone Cory asks what's the best way
to grow a following or a community from
nothing Cory this is easy for me to
answer since I've done it a couple of
times and and the real answer is content
and context my belief is the best way to
build a following right now is to put
out daily if you can content and get as
close to that as possible right and so
every day put out your picture or your
drawing on your snapchat that you blast
out or your Instagram photos or your
video show or whatever you may be doing
your written blog every day you know six
days is better than five days and five
days is better than four days and four
days is better than three days in two
days is better than one
day a week but if you're doing it one or
two or three days a week are you really
doing it so pumping out hard core
content and then engaging I'm going to
ask a question of the day today and
hopefully after I get home at 11:30
12:00 tonight I'm going to go into the
comments and reply to some of those
answers creating context you've
empowered me by watching my show I then
jumped back in to answer your question
they answer showing you that I
appreciate you we've created a deeper
context just like what I reply to you or
answer your email or some of the cyber
dusts I've done the last 24 hours
it's about content and context building
community takes work building community
is not a foregone conclusion everybody
just thinks you're going to start a show
and everything's going to magically
happen or you start a blog and you're
gonna already become an Instagram
sensation the talent to put out the
content is only one piece of the
equation one percent of the magic one
percent get it just by the content push
out but for the rest of us chaps and
chat bets we've got to put in the work
into the community and care back to the
time they've allocated the fact that
people are spending 10 minutes to watch
this in your ridiculously busy world is
something I will never ever take for
granted John asks tea or coffee
or one John the answer these days is
water but you know overall it's funny I
would say tea and its wine it's one out
of those beverages that root beer would
have been more interesting but I would
say goes wine tea coffee
Eric asks as a business leader what's
the one thing that keeps you up at night
Eric this is interesting I I promised
myself when I started this show that I
would go really direct right I mean I
already have the benefit of Steve
picking the questions so meaning that
you know there's no reason not to go
direct and honest on these this is gonna
be a little bit of a douchey answer so
d-roc I know you know how to edit can
you create a little t-shirt thing here
going this would be a little bit of a
douchey answer but it's the truth as a
business leader the one thing that I
most worry about every day is my health
because the truth is if I am healthy I
am completely unscared of any of the
landscape or shifts definitely the
competition internal issue like I feel
like I'm in complete control there's no
place in the world that I feel more
completely and utterly in control than
running a business Daniel asks Center or
edge Daniel edge Ville asks what's the
best way for a right hook to seem like a
jab bill bill bill bill bill am I happy
with you because you've asked a question
that means so much to me and it's
something that so many of you are
confused by bill I really appreciate you
and I'm not trying to sting but it might
feel a little like that uh trying to
make a right hook feel like a jab is
what 99% of salespeople and businesses
do that end up failing it is in the
clear honesty and clear track of when I
want to do something nice for you I just
do it Allah this show I just want to
take 15 to 20 minutes of my day to share
the god-given wisdom and the work
experience and I want all of you to
watch it and I want this in return
now come 15 months from now 18 months
from now whether it's a book whether
it's a seminar whether it's an event
whether it's me selling rare toys who
knows what it might be
then I will clearly say buy this
frigging rare toy it's 9.99 buy it now
but up until that point I will have very
clear there will be no show where you're
watching the show and behind the scenes
right now there's subliminal music
pumping I the damn cat for $9.99 there
is none of that and so there's a massive
fusion in the marketplace bill that
people want to disguise the sale and
there is no disguise authentically all
in all of it all in give when it's time
to give on the flip side there's a
crapload of Mother Teresa's and think
it's so nice and awesome and if you're
just good it's good no you need to sell
so when you sell you say I'm selling I
am selling this and I feel comfortable
when I put a link out buy my book it's
out buy it if I've done anything for you
buy it so the answer to question is very
simple there is no version of that that
is a losing mentality and execution and
I highly recommend that you take it and
you split it very hard apart where the
jabs are clear and where the right hooks
are clear Jason asks how can a public or
government institution use social media
more effectively in marketing campaigns
ie to increase voter turnout Jason the -
Jason the truth to that answer is
believe it or not is to become more
nimble and authentic
there is no campaign when when there
isn't the right process up top what I
mean by that is a lot of government
institutions are coming from the wrong
place for example I know that you know
just from little politics I don't talk
politics very often but like that the
Democratic Party wants more voter
turnout and the Republican Party
historically has not these are little
tidbits I picked up in the last 12 years
and I could be wrong by that they're
just people in the game that I've heard
things like that so where are you coming
from is really the question I mean to
use social to attract more voters the
truth is whether you're Republican or
Democrat you're trying to not recruit
more voters you're trying to recruit
more voters that are going to vote for
you right and so right there by its own
definition you've got an interesting
kind of perplexed situation that the
seed is tinted by the outcome and so to
the best of one's ability I think it's
important to try to get the religion at
the top to really execute I mean look
social media is probably the most
consumer insight driven marketing tool
we've ever seen the data that you can
apply on top of social to drive the
results whether to get somebody to vote
for an election to buy a cat to whatever
it may be there's never been anything
greater and so using I've said it before
Facebook dark posts with a combination
of Google long tail search SEM can get
you very very very far guys thank you so
much for watching episode 8 I really
appreciate that and I'm going to leave
you with this phenomenal question of the
day what is your current favorite single
beverage get specific in there I want to
get to know you you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
mix the questions ethics show show show
show show